feel like there was other stuff that oh
you speak of toilets I went to um and
when we were in Rotterdam there's a game
uh that I've played a bunch
um called uh we were here or uh we were
together or something it's I guess if we
were here and they have like a bunch of
puzzle games and the game devs are in uh
Rotterdam right and so they invited uh
me and reinho to go and play uh the game
she went she went to the studio
they were super chill everyone was
really nice and I asked I was like hey
so what's the uh was it was the toilet
at and they're like I just just got to
get on this was like oh don't worry
about the what's in there I was like
what what do you mean don't worry about
it okay so I walk in and I I open the
toilet and I'm like huh I look up and
there's a noose hanging from the top of
the toilet and I was like uh what yeah
it was a noose a noose on on top of the
toilet and I I go outside and I'm like
Hey so uh what's the deal with the Noose
and they were like oh
um crunch time be like there you are
yeah I was like man I know you guys are
working for rock stars
they said it was a Halloween decoration
and I was like from like two months
early or yeah from from 10 months ago so
yeah it was a Halloween decoration but
it was a very funny image I took a
picture it looks it looks so funny
because it's just a toilet with a noose
coming down from it and I was like wow
that's a
it was very funny but they were already
Sweet and that was that was cool that's
kind of when I like touring the most is
when we get to kind of do these cool
opportunities that because I would never
be in Rotterdam I would never go to
Rotterdam otherwise like there's no
reason I would ever be there uh unless I
was just there casually and I feel like
then I if I was that casually I wouldn't
mention it right I wouldn't make a big
deal about it yeah so it's really cool
that's what I really like about doing
the tours here to kind of do these
really interesting experiences that you
never would have the chance to do yeah
because like I feel like having you know
we had sometimes less than a day in the
city but it's weird sometimes you just
get the vibe of the city and a place
like if you get a Vibe of like if you'd
want to come back you know like for
example I've
I could see myself coming back to I
think like I think Copenhagen I really
want to come back to uh try out all of
the hot dogs as well uh I think a place
like mostly the hot dogs yeah I think a
place like Oslo I got the vibe and if I
go back to Norway I'd rather go far up
north yeah you know rather than going to
the city I think I'd rather explore the
rest uh of Norway yeah uh one one place
that really stuck out to me was
Stockholm just because like I kind of
got the chance to actually like go into
the city center and like kind of very
green go around it's it's beautiful like
very very traditional like kind of Old
Europe style
um I went to like a bunch of record
stores in Stockholm and it was just like
the the vibe was like perfect yeah and
I'm just like I want to come back here
and actually like you know maybe go to
like you know the outskirts of Sweden
stuff like that actually go see the
countryside I think it'd be really dope
also I don't know if it was just like uh
a subliminal thing but for some reason I
stepped out of the airport in Stockholm
and I'm like I think this is the
cleanest air I've ever breathed in my
life in a city I don't I don't know it
just it just fell super [__] I don't
know don't you have like a
like
I think it was something there was some
factoid or something that it was like
yeah Sweden has uh like the greenest
cities in the world like yeah it was
just so clean and like pristine and but
like it still kind of had that like
liveliness of a big city and it was just
I don't know how they did it but you
guys did it yeah fun vibe yeah honestly
we didn't go to a place that was bad at
all probably because we didn't stop off
in Paris you know
yeah I mean we were like so to any
French people to went to our shows we
are sorry but yeah also you know we have
to play to the crowd yeah you saw it
coming come on apparently everyone in
Europe uh loves to clown on France oh
they love clowns yeah yeah especially uh
French cuisine as well yeah French
cuisine because there's a river question
in the show that was uh we'd ask the
audience uh to fill out a QR codes like
in the the American tour yeah we'd ask
them which country has the most
overrated Cuisine and without fail
France was number one even close yeah
sometimes it was like 50 of the vote or
four times the next one it was like it
was pretty impressive how universally
people agreed that French food was
overrated you know what surprised me
though because we we talk about French
food being number one in every show but
I'll tell you what was also in every
show Oh yeah Italian food being second
yeah every show the Italian every single
European country agreed that uh Italian
food was overrated which is weird yeah
that's a weird take I've never heard
anyone say they thought Italian food was
overrated yeah like what about Italian
food is overrated I don't know maybe
it's just everyone just likes it Pizza
Pasta overrated maybe because it's just
so you know you can get it anywhere and
it's been so commercialized I mean
granted you know not every like Italian
restaurant I've been to has been like
[__] 10 out of 10 or anything like
sure there's some bad Italian
restaurants but like I've never thought
it to be like overrated yeah no no
that's a different vibe you know I was
also impressed by uh we asked the
audience as well in every show game
which anime they thought had the worst
fandom and I don't know how do they all
just do this every single show said my
hero Academia how do they all know every
single how do they as number one I just
like how do they all come together and
have this all collective experience or
are they also almost every single one
second place was one piece not everyone
though not everyone almost not everybody
not everyone it was always top three
always top three that's I mean that
didn't surprise me so much why is my
hero always like why my hero surprised
me the most because I thought I thought
everyone thought that most people are
just stopped watching my heroes I had to
have a fan base
they definitely are not the most vocal
fan base anymore
um
yeah because I was surprised because uh
Demon Slayer never never got out there
Demon Slayer never got up there it's too
generic you know uh like you just guys
never got up there either uh that
sometimes fake got up there a few times
came together to uh clown on my hero
Academia fans and God knows they're
taking enough else guys come on like do
we really need to give them another one
the show is already pretty rough it's
not doing well
like what season are we [__] on right
now like six or something seven seven
we're going on season seven yeah yeah
yeah that was the Seven Seasons yeah and
it sucks because season six was the best
season in a long time no and then
everyone's still clowning on them I was
like
oh man you hate to see it you hate to
see it they're trying the best but how
was it um for you guys you guys got to
play in front of you know your home
crowd you know Wales and London like how
was that for you guys yeah
um I was [__] so to me like I've
never seen you that nervous
uh yeah I was I wasn't like okay so
there's like two kind of like nervous
right there's one where you're kind of
like dreading it and there's one where
you just want to do it you're gonna be
on there you want to be on there uh and
you just want it to be the best thing it
can be sure I got like the second kind
of nerve as well I was just like it was
it was my home you know my home country
all of my friends and family were there
I had like I think over half of the
people that attended my wedding were at
this show oh [__]
um so like so many of my family members
were there so I just wanted to get on
and make sure that it was like the best
that it can be and more importantly that
I was like in top form as well uh and
yeah I think the London show was [__]
incredible but it was surreal like
performing in front of friends and
family uh
yeah I was trying I was trying to think
back because we like do you guys have a
routine when you go on at all do you
guys have like a way to like mentally
prep yourself well you've you played
chess this time let's just I just sit
there which I'm just like all right I
just have to talk yeah I'm gonna talk so
much for two hours yeah one one thing
because one thing I did realize is that
talking before the show actually makes
it worse for me really you know I'd
rather sit in silence the hour before
the show uh but what I had like this
many friends and family I was just like
all right guys I'm gonna talk for five
minutes and then I'm gonna go I'm sorry
I I need time to like decompress and
just like get in like the right mental
state before getting on stage but it is
also yeah because we hadn't seen our
friends in so long and they were super
super excited to talk yeah yeah I'm I'm
[__] holding my chi right now
like I can't I'll talk to you guys after
this year give me five minutes it's like
one percent of my power yeah it's like
Naruto like [__] sage mode where he
has to sit still and not be touched
that's like me before going on stage but
it's such a weird thing to explain to
people because I guess if you've never
done it you've been on stage before if
you've ever been on stage of Philly
you'd probably relate to it
um because you just need that you just
need to focus I don't know why yeah you
need to like not think and just just
have a blank slate when you go out there
yeah so you can push everything onto it
yeah um I don't really have like a
routine or anything if anything I think
sitting in silence for me makes me more
nervous right because like it makes me
think about oh I have to go on stage
whereas if I'm talking to someone just
chatting and bantering then it kind of
distracts me from the fact that I need
to go on and so when the time you know
when it is time to go up on stage I'm
like oh okay it's time yeah and then I'm
nervous for maybe like you know 30
seconds before we go on and then I'm
good yeah but if I sit there in silence
then then I'm just going to be
ruminating over the fact that there's
like okay I gotta nail This I Gotta nail
This I Gotta make sure this joke hits I
gotta make sure this all goes well and
it just I think it just adds more
pressure yeah in a weird way I don't
know it's weird yeah I mean I think
every one I've you know where you
realize that every everyone has a
different kind of like approach into
especially like a high pressure moment
because I I attribute it it's gonna
sound like a weird [__] comparison
but I attribute it to uh doing my final
exams in uni right okay okay so like you
have like you have like two hours and
all of your year has led up to this one
moment and you've studied for it
hopefully hopefully you've studied for
it but you know that the last 10 minutes
no matter how much you try to cram none
of it's gonna stick in so like for me
the best thing the best thing I tried to
do before going into my final exams was
just like [__] chill out and try to
calm my mind yeah so that that was kind
of like the same kind of mental state as
I had when I was gonna go on stage
performing it's like a it's like
competing if you've ever competed in
anything like and you've cared a lot
about it yeah is that 10 minutes before
you have to go and do the match or
something you're like oh okay all right
yeah yeah like home hold my energy and I
gotta feel like I focus when I get out
there it's kind of like that too yeah
but after a while I mean we've done the
show
30 plus times now 33 33 times I could do
it in my sleep yeah yeah I mean
definitely like I think now it's just
like kind of in our system now where we
don't even really think about it anymore
yeah you know I feel the shows some
instances have got a little bit scarfed
the sense